now what if I were to tell you that
saturated fats are not as bad as they
say they are would you believe that
comment down below I'm curious what your
thoughts are so after this video I think
you may shift your viewpoint on these
saturated animal fats because without
them it's very difficult to create
Health all of your fat soluble nutrients
can be gotten from saturated fats and I
did a whole video on this if you if you
haven't seen it I'll put the link down
below but these fat soluble nutrients
are crucial for creating
so many positive changes to your body
number two your immune system will
function much better when you consume
enough of these saturated animal fats I
mean let's just take vitamin A which is
so important for viruses okay and what
about vitamin D essential for your
immune system and so going low fat will
weaken the immune system number three
and this is the biggie Child Development
okay
as a woman who's pregnant okay it's so
important to consume enough saturated
animal fats to provide the nutrients
that this growing child needs especially
when you're pregnant and when you're
lactating vital vital vital and so this
provides all the raw material that this
child needs as well as the trace
minerals and the B vitamins and
especially these fat soluble nutrients
the worst thing that a mother could do
with the child is actually going a
low-fat diet not a good idea all right
number four your skin is a combination
of protein and fat and so without the
right fats your skin is going to look
older it's not going to look youthful
if you want beautiful youthful skin as
you age you definitely do not want to
Omit this from your diet the same thing
with your hair if you're going low fat
it's going to be dried up brittle and
not look vibrant
all right number five brain did you
realize that most of your brain is
mainly fat and cholesterol and so you
need DHA which is an omega-3 fatty acid
for cognitive function
um what was that memory Focus
concentration okay all right number six
saturated fat reduce and release bile
salts the very thing that you need to
help break down fats is actually made
from cholesterol and that's where bile
comes from cholesterol and if you don't
consume enough saturated fats you're not
going to release enough bile in fact one
of the symptoms of a low-fat diet is
gallstones what's the gallstones that is
a deficiency of bile that causes this
cholesterol to crystallize and get
really concentrated
so we need fat to help the release of
this bile all right number seven calcium
absorption
that's vitamin D right without vitamin D
your absorption of calcium can go down
by 20 times all right number eight fat
in your food allows you to be satisfied
so you can actually do intermittent
fasting much more efficiently without
enough fat in the diet you're always
just going to be hungry all the time
um all right number nine your hormones
the sex hormones estrogen progesterone
testosterone and also cortisol all is
made from fat okay so without that fat
you're not going to have the raw
material to make these hormones all
right your mood is affected by certain
hormones that are made from fat when
people go on Lower fat diets or less
animal products I do know that they get
more anxiety they get more depression
I'll put some links down below so you
can see that link number 11 your bone
health why because vitamin D is a fat
soluble nutrient and you need that to
prevent
osteoporosis osteopenia and osteomalacia
which is
softening of your bones as well as
rickets all right 12. your gut health if
you have a gut problem whether it's
inflammation or an autoimmune disease of
your gut and you have digestive issues
bloating all that and you just stay away
from these animal fats okay you stay
away from animal Foods oh my goodness is
your gut going to be inflamed even more
so one amazing thing to do if you have
an autoimmune condition of your gut is
to increase the fat okay not as much
protein moderate protein but more fat
and you're going to notice that your gut
is going to feel really good A lot of
the bloating will go away I remember
having a tremendous amount of gut issues
actually in my late 20s and all through
the 30s and it wasn't until I started to
increase more fat
I remember eating like hamburger and
meats and stuff with more fat I was like
why doesn't my stomach hurt anymore it
felt so good so in other words you may
find that your gut responds way better
to animal fat than any other thing that
you can eat now before you leave I just
have to share this one thing with you
which is
actually quite fascinating okay there's
this thing called the eat Lancet
commission uh this group that wants to
basically get the entire planet to eat
in a certain way okay and they have a
lot of scientists lined up and they have
this whole agenda and it's mostly
political but this is what they're
recommending and you're going to hear
more and more about this which
all I'm going to say is just don't drink
the Kool-Aid because it's totally not
based on any science at all and I'm
going to put some links down below so
you can see that it's not just me that's
refuting
this information it's some credible
scientist okay so this is the plan this
is the diet they want to put everyone on
okay let's start with saturated fats
they want you to consume no more than
11.8 grams of saturated fat okay that's
96 calories all right that comes out to
two and a half teaspoons and I'm not
kidding okay this is not a joke
they think that for your health that you
should only consume two and a half
teaspoons of saturated fat beef lamb
pork
this is what they recommend no more than
14 grams okay 14 grams that's 30
calories
okay now one ounce of meat is 28.3 grams
so what they're recommending and I'm not
kidding is one half of an ounce of meat
okay per day not per meal but per day so
in other words what you're allowed to
eat per day is only one mouthful of meat
just one piece of meat that's it that's
what they think you need to stay healthy
but of course
they do allow you to consume added sugar
at 31 grams that's six teaspoons
so explain to me how this is going to
contribute to your health
and also explain to me there are other
recommendation of whole grains being 232
grams okay that's 811 calories so they
want you to eat more whole grains for
your health okay and Less meat and less
saturated fat please please comment down
below and explain to me is there
something I'm missing is there something
about this that's going to increase my
health now since we talked about animal
saturated fats I think it's appropriate
now to talk about leafy greens and
salads okay so let me put that video up
right now check that one out